[Music]
hi everyone i'm super excited to be here
so
this is my last slide and i'm gonna go
back to the beginning
so that was a quick preview of what i'm
going to talk about um
uh so i'm going to talk today about
being an our blogger so
here on my first slide there are many
ways in which you can get in touch with
me
uh feel free to take a photo thank you
that's work yeah it's very nice
um so i have a website maybe some of you
have seen it before
i write a lot of blogs about our
packages
about statistics stuff sometimes just
about random opinions that no one cares
about but
you know it's fun it's a great way to
procrastinate um
i would like to talk first about okay if
you're interested in starting a blog
what are the main reasons you might want
to do that so the first one is to learn
something
you never realize how little you know
until you have to explain it to someone
else uh writing a blog is a great way of
realizing that
another reason is this is actually one
of my main motivations which was
like i really enjoy teaching and i
wanted a series of
examples of my teaching so if you have a
blog where you explain a lot of things
it shows that you know how to explain a
lot of things so that's pretty great
uh i also feel like it's a really great
way to practice your communication
skills for which there's often not that
many opportunities you know if you're
in academia writing scientific papers is
usually a good way to practice poor
communication skills
uh this is my favorite uh which is
procrastination so i often have those
days where i just can't actually do any
of the things i'm supposed to be doing
and really i just want to go home but
probably i shouldn't do that so maybe
i'll do something else that makes it
feel like i'm being productive
such as write a blog post um okay so
now that i've convinced you all that you
want to write blog post how do you
choose what to write about
so what i normally do is i write about
something that i just learned especially
if i had a hard time learning about it
so if you are trying to learn something
and there's no resources out there
that's a really really good indication
that there need to be some good
resources out there
um so you know why not help everyone
else not go through what you just went
through
the other is i write about things that i
want to learn so i that's what i did
with the per
package for example i was like i know i
should know more about per
so i was like i'm gonna write a blog
post about it and then i learned so much
and it was great
okay so how do you write a blog so the
blog down package is amazing it's
essentially a way of
collecting together a bunch of our
markdown documents into a web page
i also host my so i have a github
repository in which my
public folder from the blog down
rendering exists
and if you use netlify you can
essentially have it point to your git
repo
and then every time you push to your git
repo it automatically updates your
website so it's
very little overhead compared with
something like github pages
i also wrote a post about this like
three years ago
uh i'll show a link to my slides at the
end so this is probably hard to see it's
kind of at the bottom
uh okay so you should also use relevant
and interesting data so this is a
photo of an iris plant
as a great example so i also like to do
something where
instead of instead of downloading
instead of having people download data
and then having to load it in manually i
try to have it so that you can load it
inline
using a url um so it just makes it so
that it's a lot easier for
your your readers to follow along um you
also want to keep everything really
simple like explain it to your grandma
don't explain it to an expert like the
people that are reading this are people
that probably like need some help and
like i i used to kind of preface by
saying sorry if i'm giving too much
detail and people would be like that was
not too much detail that was like
spot-on and that was really nice like i
literally explained something using
stick figures once
it was great um okay so now you've
written all this stuff how do you get
the word out there so honestly the best
way to do that is to tweet about it
uh i am not a big twitter person
uh i i think people think that i am
because like when i do tweet there's
like a lot of kind of
spreading uh but it's like i tweet once
every three months
months and it's usually like hey here's
a blog post and that's been so far the
best way
for kind of showing people that i've
written a new blog post
um something else that i do is i try to
use easily googlable titles
um for example max will like this one i
have a
a carrot tutorial which is if you just
literally type in carrot tutorial it's
the second thing that pops up in google
and the title is basic tutorial of
carrot like that's going to come up
which is
kind of nice um another thing to do is
to
uh like present you know like go to our
ladies give a tutorial or at your
company or your university and there's a
lot of ways to kind of spread
the things that you've you've learned
and that you want to share and explain
and
it's a really really great way to
practice so here's a link to my slides
at the top
go forth and blog thank you